[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Álvaro Cordero la
ciudad egipcia de Sam el Shake es la
encargada de acoger la cop27 de este
2022 una serie de reuniones que llevan
dándose por más de un cuarto de siglo
con el objetivo de llegar a acuerdos
para mitigar el cambio climático
producido por la actividad económica
humana esta Cumbre se da en un momento
de urgencia en el que ya se sienten a
nivel global estos efectos algo que hace
más necesario que se lleguen a acuerdos
entre las principales países
contaminantes algo que no siempre ha
sucedido en France 24 repasamos la
historia de estas Cumbres
su origen está en 1992 cuando Naciones
Unidas organizó la Cumbre de Río de
Janeiro para tratar el cambio climático
la Cumbre acordó que por el bien de las
generaciones futuras era necesario
controlar la contaminación de las
Naciones industrializadas y el aumento
de la temperatura un discurso que no
tenía precedentes
esta semana en Río hemos visto el
comienzo pero más allá de Río debemos
seguir llevandolo a cabo por nuestra
generación y por las futuras No puede
haber otro camino algo que se cumplió en
1995 se celebró la primera cop en Berlín
y nació bajo el amparo de la firma casi
universal en 1994 de la convención marco
de la ONU sobre el cambio climático aquí
se reconoció que había un problema con
el calentamiento global y que estaba en
manos de ser del ser humano el poder
cambiarlo así hablaba la entonces
muestra de medio ambiente alemana Angela
Merkel nosotros en las Naciones
industrializadas debemos cambiar
nuestras ideas de lo que vemos como la
buena vida en el inicio de estas Cumbres
por el clima los principales actores
llamados actuar eran los países que
estaban más desarrollados
las peticiones lanzadas durante las
primeras conferencias tuvieron su
respuesta en la cop3 de kioto realizada
en 1997 las conclusiones de este acto
dieron como resultado un acuerdo
histórico en el que los países firmantes
se comprometieron a reducir las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
en al menos un 5% para 2012 desde los
niveles de 1990 hasta 192 países
firmaron o ratificaron este protocolo
ilusionante en materia medioambiental
que en un principio pareció comprometer
a las grandes potencias
Estados Unidos sigue firmemente
comprometido Con un objetivo fuerte y
vinculante que reducirá nuestras
emisiones en casi un 30% de lo que
serían un compromiso tan fuerte o más
fuerte que cualquiera de los que hemos
escuchado aquí
el imperativo aquí es hacer lo que
prometemos en lugar de prometer lo que
no podemos hacer sin embargo kyoto nunca
cumplió las expectativas depositadas Es
cierto que si intentaron regular las
emisiones con los sanciones a los países
que no cumplieran el objetivo pero el
principal escollo fue la no ratificación
de Estados Unidos y la posterior
retirada de su firma en 2001 además
algunas herramientas presentadas como el
mercado de compraventa de permisos de
emisión ayudó a las grandes potencias a
mantener o incluso aumentar sus
emisiones la excusa fue que estas
medidas previstas en un principio para
evitar desastres futuros dañaban la
economía así hablaba el expresidente
Bush el enfoque adoptado por el
protocolo de kioto
habría obligado a Estados Unidos
a realizar
recortes profundos e inmediatos en
nuestra economía para cumplir un
objetivo arbitrario pero lo que era un
problema futuro se fue convirtiendo en
algo del presente el nuevo siglo vio
como tanto las naciones ya
industrializadas como las que estaban en
vías de desarrollo aumentaron
notablemente sus emisiones Y eso
repercutió en un aumento acelerado de la
temperatura global alcanzandose Records
anuales de temperatura y comprometiendo
el futuro de muchas regiones del planeta
pero a pesar de ello las siguientes
Scott fueron evidenciando
progresivamente la falta de intención de
muchos países para hacer vinculantes los
acuerdos sobre el clima algo que se
reflejó especialmente en la cop 15 de
copenhague en 2009 donde apenas se
lograron consensos entre las naciones
más contaminantes algo claramente
contraproducente ya que la década
siguiente fue la más calurosa de la
historia
en este contexto se afrontó la cop21 de
la que surgió el acuerdo de París de
2015 este acuerdo contó con la
ratificación de Hasta 191 países gracias
a su flexibilidad el acuerdo de París
dejó de lado las obligaciones y
sanciones impuestas en kyoto para
apostar porque cada país regule
voluntariamente sus emisiones el
objetivo era que el máximo número de
Naciones se comprometiera a intentar
ralentizar el calentamiento global a un
máximo de dos grados para finales de
siglo una meta complicada pero no
imposible su principal obstáculo fue de
nuevo Estados Unidos que aunque en un
principio firmó y ratificó lo acordado
se retiró tras la llegada de Donald
Trump a la presidencia
anunció La retirada del horrible costoso
y unilateral acuerdo de París
la marcha de Estados Unidos
supuso un duro golpe para el acuerdo de
París ya que esta nación emite solamente
el 14% de todas las emisiones globales
Aunque el regreso de esta nación tras la
victoria de Joe biden 2020 llamó a la
esperanza de resucitar este acuerdo la
inacción de las Naciones del mundo tras
estas conferencias sobre el clima ha
sido usualmente muy criticada pero el
debate ya no es exclusivamente a futuro
esta cop 27 se celebra cuando la
humanidad ya está sufriendo las
consecuencias económicas y sanitarias
directas del cambio climático de ahí su
importancia ya que si no se alcanzan y
Ejecutan acuerdos nuestro futuro como
especie podría estar cada vez más
comprometido con esto concluimos Gracias
por compartir y comentar estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]